Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
En tant que professionnel
de la santé au travail,
je passe mes journées à corriger,
ou plutôt, à essayer de corriger,
les mauvaises habitudes des adultes.
Car parmi mes clients, comme dans
le reste de la population active,
presque neuf personnes sur dix ont eu
mal au dos, à la nuque ou aux épaules
au cours des 12 derniers mois.
Ces douleurs sont intimement liées
à notre façon de mener
nos activités quotidiennes,
c’est-à-dire à nos habitudes.
Or, nous savons tous bien que
changer ses habitudes, il n’y a pas
grand-chose de plus complexe.
Il est donc beaucoup plus simple
de prendre de bonnes habitudes
quand on est jeune
que de les changer plus tard.
Une récente étude australienne
a malheureusement montré que,
parmi mille jeunes issus
de populations plutôt aisées,
avec un bon accès à l’éducation,
à la santé et également aux écrans,
50 % avaient eu mal à la nuque
au cours des trente derniers jours.
30%, soit quasiment un sur trois,
déclarait avoir mal à la nuque tout le
temps ou quasiment tout le temps.
Autre résultat intéressant
de cette étude :
chaque heure supplémentaire passée
sur écran augmente de 10%
le risque d’avoir mal à la nuque.
Vous allez me dire :
« Olivier, ne t’inquiète pas.
C’est juste une photo.
Peut-être que les choses
vont de mieux en mieux. »
C’est sympa de vouloir me rassurer.
J’apprécie.
Malheureusement, la Ligue suisse contre
le rhumatisme n’est pas de cet avis.
Dans son dernier rapport,
elle a observé que
la proportion des jeunes adultes
qui ont mal au dos toutes les semaines
a bondi de 50 % en neuf ans.
Plus 50 % en neuf ans.
À ce rythme-là, on aura bientôt
une bombe de santé publique
qui nous explosera à la figure.
Il y a donc urgence à agir
avec méthode et détermination.
La stratégie que je propose
repose sur trois piliers
que sont la réglementation,
l’éducation et la collaboration.
La réglementation, c’est toujours
une arme à double tranchant
parce que certains vont imaginer qu’on
leur tord le bras et donc ils résistent.
Là, il ne s’agit pas de tordre
le bras de qui que ce soit,
il s’agit simplement de créer
des environnements d’apprentissage
qui soient sains pour nos enfants.
Pour comprendre cette idée, faisons un
tout petit tour dans le monde des adultes.
Dans le monde des adultes,
il y a des choses qu’on appelle les lois
sur la santé et la sécurité au travail.
Quand ces lois sont bien appliquées,
les adultes qui travaillent dans un bureau
sont assis sur du mobilier
qui est relativement confortable.
Ils ont les pieds par terre,
au pire sur un repose-pieds.
Et ça, ça leur donne un appui
pour se projeter au fond du siège.
Et au fond du siège,
leur bassin,
ou plus exactement leur ceinture,
ira se poser
contre la partie basse du dossier,
qu’on appelle le support lombaire.
Et c’est ce transfert qui permettra
de soulager les tissus
et donc de les protéger.
Retour dans le monde des enfants.
Maintenant, on ouvre la porte d'une
école et d'une classe de primaire.
Là, vous voyez quoi ?
Vous voyez des enfants
qui ont tous les pieds en l’air
parce que le mobilier est trop haut
Et même s’il n’était pas trop haut,
de toute façon, ils ne pourraient pas
toucher le dossier
parce qu’il est aussi trop profond.
Et même s’il n’était pas trop profond,
c’est-à-dire ni trop haut ni trop profond,
au moment où ils arrivent
contre le dossier avec le bassin,
ils rencontreraient quoi ?
Un trou !
Comment vous voulez être soutenu
par un trou ?
Ce n’est pas possible.
Peut-être pire encore -
je ne sais pas si c’est pire -
quand je suis bien assis
en position neutre,
je suis sur les ischions,
ceux qu’on appelle les os des fesses.
Comment voulez-vous rester plus que
dix minutes sur les os des fesses
sur une chaise qui est aussi dure ?
Vous vous brûlez les fesses !
Par conséquent, le mobilier qui est
mis à la disposition de nos enfants
ne leur permet pas d’être assis
de façon confortable.
En d’autres termes, il ne passerait pas
la rampe dans le monde des adultes,
c’est-à-dire qu’aujourd’hui,
la réglementation protège mieux
les corps solides des adultes
que les corps fragiles
et en croissance de nos enfants.
Pour remettre de l’ordre là-dedans,
il va falloir une intervention de l’État.
Cette intervention sera nécessaire,
mais elle ne sera jamais suffisante.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que je peux complètement être
avachi sur une chaise de luxe.
Il n'y a pas de contradiction.
Vous le voyez, en matière de santé,
le curseur de la responsabilité
est exactement à mi-chemin
entre les conditions matérielles,
organisationnelles, environnementales,
et les comportements.
Qui dit comportement,
dit habitude, dit éducation.
Alors, regardons comment se passe
l'éducation posturale à l'école.
On va reprendre notre enfant qui était
en train de se brûler les fesses.
Comme il se brûle les fesses, il est
avachi et se tortille dans tous les sens.
Son instit, en voyant ça,
sait bien que cet enfant n’est plus
dans la dynamique du cours.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’on ne peut pas être concentré sur
ses fesses et sur son prof en même temps.
Il faut choisir.
Donc,
(Rires)
cet instituteur, animé par les
meilleures intentions du monde,
va aller vers l’enfant et va lui dire :
« Tiens-toi droit
et recule tes épaules ! »
Je le refais.
« Tiens-toi droit, recule tes épaules ! »
Ai-je vraiment l’air d’un type
dans une posture confortable
qui est en train
de prendre soin de son dos
et qui va continuer à aller bien
pendant longtemps ?
Ce prof, en dépit de ses excellentes
intentions, n’a rien résolu du tout
en disant à l’enfant :
« Tiens-toi droit. »
Il l’a projeté d’une posture extrême
à une autre posture extrême.
Il a remplacé un problème
par un autre problème,
alors qu’il avait une alternative.
Regardez.
Quand l’enfant était avachi,
il pouvait juste lui faire observer
que, quand on est avachi
et qu’on met la main dans le dos,
on peut sentir les vertèbres qui sortent.
C’est un peu comme caresser un crocodile -
ça ne sert à rien d’essayer, croyez-moi.
Donc vous caressez le crocodile.
Et quand vous tournez sur votre bassin,
vous voyez qu’au moment
où vous arrivez sur les ischions,
le crocodile disparaît.
Là, il est là ;
là, il n’est plus là.
Facile.
Vous allez me dire : « C’est gentil,
tes histoires d’animaux,
mais crocodile ou pas, je ne peux pas
tenir comme ça toute la journée. »
Qui a parlé de toute la journée ?
Bien sûr qu’il faut bouger,
on est tous d’accord.
Le problème, c'est qu'après nous avoir
raconté n'importe quoi sur la posture,
on va maintenant nous raconter
n’importe quoi sur le mouvement.
On va nous dire :
« Le mouvement, c’est la santé,
la bonne posture, c’est la suivante. »
Qui n’a jamais entendu ça ?
« Le mouvement, c’est la santé ? »
Très bien.
Comment vous expliquez alors
que les pompiers, les concierges,
le personnel de ménage, les jardiniers,
aient mal au dos ?
Ils ne bougent pas assez ?
Et si la bonne posture,
c’était la suivante,
ça veut dire que je pourrais me tortiller
la journée entre n’importe quelle posture,
j’irais bien le soir ?
Vous voyez bien que ça ne tient pas
la route, on est dans le n’importe quoi.
L’art de la posture, c’est l’art
de la précision dans la durée.
Précision dans les concepts,
précision dans les mots,
précision dans l’exécution.
Et la précision est très mal véhiculée
par les formules simplistes
qu’on a tous trop entendues.
Il y a donc un vrai travail d’éducation,
voire de rééducation,
à faire sur le thème de la posture,
que ce soit à l’école ou à la maison,
ce qui nous ramène au rôle central
de l’institution scolaire.
Vous allez vous dire :
« Olivier, il ne mâche pas ses mots.
D’abord, il accuse l’école
de casser le dos des enfants
en les mettant sur du matériel
qui n’est pas ergonomique.
Ensuite, il accuse l’école
d’empêcher les enfants
de prendre de bonnes habitudes.
Grosso modo, il accuse l’école
d’être le lieu de tous les problèmes. »
Ma pensée est un peu plus nuancée que ça.
Le fond de ma pensée,
c’est que l’école pourrait et devrait être
le lieu de toutes les solutions.
Pensons à une autre problématique
de santé publique
à propos de laquelle
l’école a joué un rôle moteur.
J'entends par là la prévention
des caries dentaires.
Quand on a décidé de prendre les caries
au sérieux, qu’est-ce qu’il s’est passé ?
Tout le monde s’est mis
à tirer sur la même corde
pour finalement livrer à nos enfants
un message précis et simple à la fois :
« Il ne faut pas manger trop de sucre
et il faut se brosser les dents. »
Résultat des courses ? Oui, on a toujours
des caries dentaires, bien sûr,
mais la culture et les pratiques
ont évolué dans le bon sens.
Tout le monde, c’était qui ?
C’étaient les parents, les instituteurs,
les professionnels de santé,
les industriels,
les autorités et les assureurs.
Les caries dentaires,
c’est un problème d’accumulation,
d’accumulation de sucre sur les dents.
Les troubles musculo-squelettiques,
c’est aussi un problème d’accumulation,
d'accumulation de charge biomécanique
sur les tissus.
Les solutions qui ont marché pour l’un
marcheront donc pour l’autre.
Ce que je suis en train de dire,
c’est qu’on n’a pas besoin
de réinventer la roue.
On a juste besoin d’ouvrir nos placards,
de reprendre ce qu’on a déjà testé,
de le dépoussiérer, de l’adapter
et de le mettre en œuvre.
L’objectif de protection de la santé
de nos enfants
est donc réaliste et atteignable pour
autant qu’on s’y mette tous ensemble.
Et le plus tôt sera le mieux.
(Applaudissements)